[Music]
i know what you did last summer i know
what you did last summer yeah well we
were together and it was a quarantine
and so um i in fact i can assume what a
lot of people listening did last summer
you don't both have to know what each
other did last summer
i did a lot of gardening i started
cooking i got really into cooking and
there were certain things i did last
year you let your hair grow
literally and metaphorically
not really metaphorically mostly just
literally uh yeah i got a man bun you
were like you look like i mean not in
the face but tom cruise's character and
magnolia
and i didn't have the same regrets about
my father unfortunately um yeah he is
really good in that movie oh my god i
had heard that his own that's not a hot
take nine he's always he's amazing
everyone but everyone knows he's great
in that are people sick of hearing us
talk about i'm good of an actor tom
cruise but he's i you know i heard that
his um his own father passed away
recently before before that movie right
before they shot oh and so he used a lot
of that oh and jason robards the actor
was in fact dying during that so a local
hero he lived right he lived near us
growing up i remember seeing him at
every friday night we would go to
luigi's restaurant shout out and
fairfield's still there um and
occasionally we would see jason roberts
there but i was a kid and i didn't
really understand why our parents were
like getting excited about it yeah
father who's like
not really into like
celebrity or anything like that well no
disrespect to the legendary jason
robarts but this story has really gone
off the rails it sure has hey let's get
into the show okay let's get back on the
rails yeah sure
choo-choo
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your conductor
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
chugging along with me as always on
these tracks oh life chugger like a
chugga like a chugga like a chugga
chugga is um well i'm trying to think of
what what a co-trained conductor does
there's only one conductor right
uh i don't know there's gonna be a co
conductor conductor uh my co-conductor
christian long and um
well we have a we have a little thing
coming out uh today that's exciting or
it came out a couple days ago yeah we
got a thing
one thing why are we talking about what
uh we did last summer that's a good
because we did have
i mean we had fun summers for sure last
summer we were editing our movie we were
um relaxing a bit we're trying to stay
away from people because it was the
height of the pandemic well you know
what i also was doing was getting back
in touch with the simpler things we
talked about gardening and cooking and
and um
and being more present to nature i i've
i kind of re-fell in love with the
natural world and i think a lot of
people maybe had that experience of
slowing down and taking stock of course
i'm glossing over we both are you know
why we were doing this but we don't want
to dwell on the tragic elements of it
right we're trying to make the best of
it and and what about this past summer
similar i guess i i worked i went to
bulgaria people are sick of hearing
about um but we also continued to work
on the movie in a different capacity on
our movie lady of manor which is now out
on blu-ray dvd uh and
yeah that's a good question why are we
talking well let me tie it in okay let
me tie it all together okay all right so
set the table for me we're talking about
what we did last summer because that's a
sort of a veiled reference to
the hit 90s film i think 1997
i know you did last summer which starred
among other people
the great ryan freddie prince oh
ryan phillippe current got friend of the
show
uh freddy prince jr would be a great uh
future friend of the chef yes every cast
member of that uh sarah michelle
jennifer uh
hewitt love hewitt love hewitt um but
speaking of love we love ryan right now
and we have loved him ever since uh
he he did us a huge solid by lending his
uh talents his incredible comedic gifts
gifts that i did not know he possessed
for many years of knowing him um and not
knowing him personally
but he is really really funny i mean
he's a [ __ ] i think a lot of people
might be surprised to learn that people
who saw mcgruber won't be but um
for any anybody who
isn't familiar with his comedic chops
yeah and at the risk of sounding uh
repetitive talking about
the movie lady of the manor which we've
done ad nauseam on this podcast i'm sick
i'm sick of hearing about it uh but
we're gonna do a little more because
ryan
was in the movie he was great in the
movie and um
we're gonna talk about it because it's
it's our show yeah it's our show and
we're also i'm sorry we're we're proud
of it it was a one million dollar movie
low budget we we uh
a lot of people helped us make this and
um
but you know all the talking about it
and that we've been talking ad nauseam
for the last couple of weeks about as
christian said and doing as much as we
can to get it out there but um right now
it's out there and it's a very strange
feeling to have this thing that you've
worked on so hard um be out there so we
we really want to say thank you to all
the people who
who have downloaded it who have streamed
it who's watched it um even if you just
bought it and did [ __ ] oh my god so many
nice comments that i've that we've
gotten on on the shorties on facebook
and
um on instagram like i i'm so like proud
and happy that there are people that are
find it funny and it's just like a nice
diversion for an hour and a half and
they've uh
they've gotten their minds off things
for an hour and a half like that's the
goal yeah that was always our goal we
wanted to make something that made us
laugh um it it makes us laugh and so
we're so happy that it's making some of
you laugh too and uh thank you for
checking it out because it is one of
those small movies that you really have
to um
talk about a lot maybe to an annoying
point like we have right so get it out
so our guest today ryan was so
kind and generous to be in our movie
because he's used to being in much much
much bigger movies yes that people know
like cruel intentions and the
aforementioned i know you did last
summer
we talked about our father's great
movies i mean he's in a stop loss we
talked about today um we don't talk
about 54 but that's one of my favorite
performances of his he's
uh
gosford park yes that's right god he
worked with robert altman um he was uh
you know for a long time he has been in
the public consciousness he has been
uh one of like our foremost actors hunky
actors and i think his looks have
definitely for me my perspective of him
overshadowed uh his real gifts as an
actor which which are how really how
funny he is and and what it what a gift
for comedy he has and um so we talked
about that and of course if you've seen
lady the man or you already know that
but like christian said we were he was
really kind to to come down and
do that movie with us but more than that
it was the way he did it i just remember
he was so patient and uh it was on there
was a lot of waiting around and it
wasn't like a you know didn't have a
nice trailer to go back those those
things that a lot of actors get on
bigger budget movies um it required a
lot more patience we've talked about
melanie and judy uh but ryan
was really hung in there with us
so we hope you guys hang in there with
us talking about lady of the manor and
uh in the show in general and i have to
say ryan is
so handsome that i apologize to all of
you for not being able to see him it's
unfortunate this isn't filmed it is uh
but not this part
no that's this is this is fine this
isn't films
it's for the best uh but ryan you'll be
deprived of um his face but i'll put
something on instagram and again if you
haven't seen it check it check out his
face in lady of the manor uh but right
now here he is uh the very funny um our
friend and um the star of lady of the
manor one of the stars
the
handsome i mean duh ryan
life could be a dream sweetheart
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear and
exclusives like the christmas pig by jk
rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello
[Music]
it's a little appropriate i think only
because i feel like this was
and this is not a brag in fact this is
like an admission i feel like this was
my energy on set a lot um yeah did i
think so
but
i think it's also part of your
personality and part of your charm it
can't be that charming when you're
working with somebody who's like i'm
sorry i'm late and i'm holding people i
i it can't be charming i disagree see i
disagree because i give like a wide like
i am so socially awkward
um in in life in all ways that i i allow
people or i account i take into account
the the fact that they may be awesome
i guess i do too uh i in fact i'm
i i kind of like when i feel a little
bit more balanced when people are the
other person's thrown off you know it
kind of kind of helps me find my money
so you're welcome yeah but also isn't
that where most of like my favorite
humor comes from is like uncomfortable
all totally you know i think and there's
a lot of that in lady of the matter you
know there's certainly elements of that
in mcgruber
i i love when
when you know and it makes me also think
a lot about
oh fast and like
that was his wheelhouse absolutely when
people were at their most uncomfortable
or didn't know how to react that's when
he was thriving it's the moments of
silence it's what you did on um i want
to talk about norm but
it's what you did on kyle dunnigan's uh
show recently that was so funny
you and that's what christian i've been
talking about for the last couple of
days because we're like
just in awe of what you did in our movie
but but um
specifically like
your ability to do that to invest in
those awkward moments and and never
like wink at the camera there's no never
you did this in our movie you did this
in mcgruber um you never play the joke
how hard is that to do when you're when
you're opposite somebody like will forte
or kyle dunnigan like how do you how do
you dig in and not laugh
well i think the hardest part about that
is is that i'm a fan
of those people at my core so there's
parts there's times when we're making
mcgruber i'm relatively prepared for
when will
says the lines that are on the page
when he improvs and i don't know what's
coming and he is one of the most like
quick-witted genius fearless performers
and that's when i i have to like resort
to some causing myself some kind of
physical pain like either i'll bite the
inside of my cheek or i'll dig my
fingernail into my thumb as hard as i
can just to distract myself
um because that does become a real
challenge like playing the straight man
is not easy
in those situations i mean you know in
mcgruber with will and kristen
their costumes alone are ridiculous you
know we had some of that in in our movie
as well but like you know and there and
it will get right up in your face and
they'll start doing a baby voice and i'm
like how the hell am i not supposed to
well react or laugh to this you know i
and and you know again with like kyle
dunnigan i just think is
unbelievably talented i'm the biggest
fan of his i would do anything he asked
me to do and be a part of um and even in
doing that little bit with him it's like
i would rather be watching it than being
in it in some ways
how did that mcgruber thing happen
because i was surprised to see you in
that um i i think a lot of people
were
how did did you is that just a simple
audition was that something that will
had approached you about no um i got a
call to do the read-through
and
and my representatives are really
dismissive about it they're like they're
like uh you know that we got called
would you you know there was this thing
called mcgruber
they're like you know would you want to
do the read through i'm like mcgruber
are you like are you serious to me
as a lifelong fan of snl like i've
literally watched every episode um
i was so excited they thought that i
would never want to even go near that
material but it was i had the exact
opposite reaction
and so they just asked me to do the read
through
and i went in and i was terrible
because i was trying to be funny i
thought they wanted i thought because it
was magruber and it was gonna and it was
so silly and it was written so funny in
such a funny manner that i also had to
like
come with a character and so i i did
that i did this character that was like
uh
so far from
where i ended up in in in the film um
and so it didn't go well it makes sense
like that that probably most people's
instinct is to try to i mean that's what
he's he's an absurd character you see it
on saturday love so you you probably
also feel like you have to prove
yourself because you're not you weren't
at that point known for doing comedy
exactly and and i thought that the whole
thing was meant to be heightened but
it's not and so it was yorma the
director who who was saying no we want
this to feel like an 80s action movie
and the only person who's really meant
to be super ridiculous is magruber
himself and also vicki kristen wiig um
and so it and and i've seen this
indoctrination take place now on the
series with people like lawrence
fishburne who who's and sam elliot you
know it helps i guess having seen the
movie and to see how powers booth played
it and how i played it but
yorma and and john solomon they both
co-directed the uh the episodes this
season
would tell every actor no you play this
as if it's
the stakes are as high as they can be
everything is as real as possible and
then let the other stuff happen around
you i think that's the genius of that
movie it's the way you guys are playing
it will's obviously so funny but like
the only he's allowed to be because of
how people are playing it like that
right and if everybody and so that was
the thing too is like so the movie comes
out it bombs terribly we we all were
devastated uh never thought we'd be
revisiting that material or that
universe again you know but the
opportunity comes up to do the series
and in in the time between the release
of the movie and now it's become like a
cult favorite it's ended up on on lists
of top 20 comedies of the last 20 years
and every like comedian wanted to be in
in the series
you know so yorma was telling me like he
turned down like ben stiller and jonah
hill and all these people he said
because he's like you'd be bummed if
you're you know you can't populate a
story like that with all funny people
it's gonna diffuse
what is valuable at the core of the
thing you know if everybody's trying to
be funny it's going to lower the overall
humor across totally you know i always
find that on i love curb and i know you
love curb your enthusiasm i i always we
talked a little bit about that
you you can always tell i mean that
that's on that show in particular you
can always tell you can see it and play
there when somebody's trying to be funny
or they come in um with expectations to
be funny uh rather than just kind of
because it takes a certain amount of
that's what you did at mcgruber is
really
something we we think is special because
you it takes a certain amount of
confidence to
to do that to especially when you get
what's funny and when you're a fan of
comedy to let somebody be doing all the
funny stuff and just and just be a
sounding board you know just be reactive
you're like totally reactive in that
movie um
was it was that a challenge or was it
like once you understood the thing was
it easy to stay in your lane it was yeah
once i was recalibrated once i was told
you know this is you're in an action
movie you just have to deal with this
goofy
insane ridiculous partner but like
that's not who you are you know and once
once i understood that and then i would
just apply it to because i have done
other action and and mostly drama
throughout my career and i'm like that's
just
that's that's the way just play it
straight play it real play as honest as
you can within the ridiculous
circumstances that ends up being just to
me just as funny some of your reactions
some of you are
i i i imagine these are the like the
hardest
it was to not laugh was when like you
said when he's in your face i mean when
he's like yeah like giving you that
aggressive like i'm gonna fight like are
you trying to make you
flinch do you remember a scene where it
was just it became impossible i mean i
feel like you're kind of hinting at it
it was the the scene on the tarmac
right before he explodes the van full of
wrestlers and he's up in my face telling
me how you know you think your [ __ ]
doesn't stink but he does and he's like
you know and and will there's no
there's no shortage
he could do a hundred takes if given the
freedom and each time say something
different and absurd and and and and so
perfect for the situation and so
that those were the times like it's
really when he when he starts doing
silly voices up in your face it's like
if anybody wants to do that to anyone in
any
realm
you're gonna you're gonna break you know
but then i became a point of pride for
me especially
in amongst that collective because
on the first film you know we seth
meyers would be on set pitching jokes in
between takes and you know akiva who's
part of lonely island and you know you
had like
it was like i was kind of getting inside
that whole snl world that i always loved
and so i wanted to rest that by not
breaking
and so it became like a real point like
that became my focus i'm like they can
everybody else can break i'm not going
to break that's going to be my thing you
know i remember how people used to talk
about like on snl
during the fallon days when he and
horatio sands would break a lot during
sketches and it was kind of like but
some people frowned upon it some people
enjoyed it but like my whole thing was
i'm gonna like prove myself by by not
breaking by by being you know that dude
i did a date two days on anchorman
uh which i got cut out of which was a
real bummer but i remember i had the
same that yeah but didn't they put you
in the deleted yeah yeah i did i saw you
yes yeah yeah of course people you're a
real student you like you love comedy so
i'm a comedy nurse 100 you are yeah i
was surprised were are people
where was that is that from snl is that
what you grew up on was it was it just a
matter of absorbing that stuff yeah it
was and in fact so i went to um like
christian school growing up
and um we didn't have an
arts program because you know that's not
that wasn't a thing
no no school dances no no rock and roll
like very very flashed or footloose but
uh one of the sketches like a senior
school sketch
um that i wrote and performed
we basically lifted the whole um dana
carvey is johnny carson thing and i
would do a ver i would do my
interpretation of dana carvey's uh
johnny carson and did this whole thing
in front of them and it was very racy
for
like we were it was subversive like we
slipped things in there that definitely
wouldn't have been approved by the
school board at this baptist school
about christianity no about the students
and about you know
uh allusions to what some of the
teachers may or may not be up to and
that kind of thing like it was
definitely
we got in a little bit of trouble
afterward but um dana carvey was one who
like i would try to do every single
character that he played i would try to
impersonate and and and like i just
admired him so much um
and so yeah snl was was like a core part
of like
my my enthusiasm for comedy um so ron
were you doing it johnny so you were
basically like a big were you doing an
impression yeah yeah i was doing dana
carvey's carson weir weird wild stuff
i remember doing that but i remember
just lifting doing his
to this day i think of bush is like
carvey's version of bush yeah yeah
and the church lady and like the church
lady was such a breakout character like
in pop culture and then wayne's world
and just all i mean he was he was he was
one of my favorites um when i was that
you know
in my teenage years or whatever did you
whip so when you first but you started
acting young i know professionally you
did um
like as a teenager you were right yeah i
mean my first real job was at 17 on a
soap opera one life to live and i played
the first gay teenager in television
history oh yeah
yeah that was the first time there had
ever been um
yeah that representation how did the
catholic school feel about that
they shunned me
and my family
yeah yeah i didn't end up graduating i
had to get a g i had to get my diploma
in in other ways
[ __ ] yeah man i was discriminated
against bullying yeah
but also you got to remember i mean you
know i don't know how much of that
would change with time in the religious
context but
you know this was before will and grace
this is before
ellen you know up until that point the
primary point of reference for a gay
character on television was billy
crystal on soap really my god or like
rip taylor from confetti right hello but
but um
yeah so it was pretty bold it was pretty
um
it's hard to imagine i know for younger
people listening to this not to sound
condescending but like you're right i
mean it was it was just such a different
landscape culturally that there was um
there was i it didn't exist i'm thinking
of the gay characters that i remember
from then it was like
it was like cartoonish like caricatures
for the most part it was or it wasn't
even directly addressed right right it
was just like they're strange so how
does that feel i mean that must not have
been an easy decision i mean on the one
hand i imagine like it's a part on a
show that people watch and it's money
and it's like for a kid who wants to be
a professional actor that's got to be
one thing
how do you reconcile
the
potential problematic part of the other
which again now it seems absurd to be
talking about it that way but did you
think it might pigeonhole you it might
um and like you said you're shunned from
your school i mean there are social
ramifications how did you contend with
that yeah and i was only 17 and i had no
sexual experience like i you know
at that age you're always afraid of what
people think about you in all regards
and and and certainly when it comes to
sexuality back then and and whatever
else but and then on top of that
you know the indoctrination
that you know you experience
spending your your formative years in a
heavily religious school also
creates this whole like is this right is
this wrong you know from a moral
standpoint
um and so
it was a difficult decision in some ways
um
but
that also happened to be my mother's
favorite television show oh really so my
mom had a daycare center in our house
growing up so i would wake up in the
morning and there would already be like
15 kids in my house before i go to
school but so when they would all go
down for naps she would watch all the
abc soaps uh all my children one life to
live general hospital and so
it was kind of crazy that my first real
job in the industry was on my mother's
favorite television show you know that's
really crazy so so
i think thankfully it was because you it
i i'm sure that was compelling i'm sure
that was part of it it was like yeah
yeah but it was you know i remember
feeling really insecure about what the
reaction would be and how people might
think of me and again like you were
saying today that seems
irrelevant you know i know it's not a
concern and in fact it's you know it's
it's it's kind of
a bonus where it's like more interesting
now because we're all everything is out
in the open
but um
but then what ended up happening is a
few months or i was i was only on it for
like three months so a few weeks in into
the show airing
we started to get this fan mail
and some of it was so emotionally
impactful
whether it was from
teenagers themselves who were saying
i've never seen
someone like me on television before or
it was it was i remember we got this one
leather letter from a mechanic a father
who said that he hadn't spoken to his
child who came out of the closet
in a year plus but started watching the
show and through this character i played
on a soap opera found his way back to
his son and a relationship
and you start reading some things like
that and it and it made all of those
fears
and all those you know considerations
about what does this mean for me my life
and how are people yeah i think it like
started to take on a whole new level of
of importance and
yeah that must change everything when
you see the effect that it has on
on people you must just think of it as a
job a job that wasn't like that easy to
take on and um
god it must yeah change people's lives
yeah and in fact you know that started
to inform as i as i got older and and my
career grew and that sort of thing i
started to gravitate towards things that
i thought had
a social message or could or could shed
some light on a topic or um because i
found that so rewarding and i still do
you know when our industry can make
people think a little differently or
open or open eyes um i think that's when
it's at its best i mean certainly the
escapism is tremendous value in this day
and age with the hell that everyone's
living through and there's nothing
better than laughter but
you know even getting to do something
like crash you know
where
it just it made people think differently
about race relations and it's it's used
um in collegiate courses now as a point
of reference about race relations and
you know i would just i would gravitate
towards
i wouldn't say message movies but but
what ones that might be able to move the
needle in some way from a society
societal standpoint
you know i i did this movie stop-loss
with kim pearce
years ago you know that was really about
this policy of of not honoring a a an
enlisted person's contract and forcing
them back into a situation they didn't
want to be in and so we made this movie
about that because kim's brother had
served and then we later hear you know
that hillary clinton watched the movie
and this this politician watched the
movie and then shortly thereafter the
stop-loss policy was was ended now i'm
not saying that we ended that policy but
i think we certainly
we were we were people were aware of it
you know they we
the people that made the decisions to
stop that from happening sold films so
that's kind of a
awesome thing
yeah that must feel that must be
to be a part of something like that that
like you said really moves the needle i
mean in a
in a drastic way that must feel
rewarding in a way that most of these
jobs don't necessarily yeah it does and
it did
similar to the letters that you got on
the soap opera there must be
soldiers and people whose kids served
who um recognized that movie and
recognize the importance of that movie
yeah and you know i've done a fair few
military themed projects and i hear
veterans all the time and i work with a
lot of veterans charities and i also
come from a military family you know
both of my my grandfathers served in
world war ii my dad served during
vietnam my uncles uh various cousins
yeah so i grew up around
those people you know and so it's always
been
important to me to to do what i could
and to represent them properly and yeah
i don't think i knew that ryan how did
that impact your decision or at least
their perception of your decision to be
an actor because that that seems like
such a
i can only imagine that that must have
added an extra layer to the
to that decision well i did sit in a
recruiter's office at age 17
with a buddy of mine who ended up
enlisting and going to fight during
desert storm and it was something that i
was seriously thinking about um
there was there were three options for
me um i was heavily into martial arts so
i wanted to i started taekwondo when i
was like
eight years old because i lived in a
rough neighborhood and i was small for
my age my parents wanted me to be able
to defend myself
so they you know we didn't have a lot of
money but they somehow scrounged up
enough to get me um
martial arts lessons and then i started
teaching kids when i was a kid myself so
when i was about 13
14 i would teach
taekwondo classes and i had it in my
head that um i was going to want to have
my own dojo someday that i was going to
want to get certified and um i didn't
know that there was this opportunity
that my my dojo presented for for
young people around my age to go to
korea and to go through this master
program and and we couldn't afford it we
couldn't afford the plane ticket for me
to go over there so
if if
my family could have afforded to fly me
there i probably never would have become
an actor i probably would have just
become a martial artist and would have
no kids taught and trained that was
enough of a passion that was the course
you were on for like that's what you
wanted to do with your life it was yeah
it definitely was good and so now i've
got a black belt in taekwondo aikido and
i've studied a little bit of muay thai
and i've always been super into that um
but yeah so it was either uh open up my
own dojo enlist in the armed forces or
become an actor and i guess i took the
path of least resistance yeah yeah i'll
say
so your parents were like they were
supportive that there was no hesitation
with them um i wouldn't they were
absolutely supportive there was a little
more hesitation on my father's part just
he's more he's a more sober individual
you know
navy you know he's a chemist
this didn't seem like a reality you know
when you don't when you don't come from
when you have no connections when you
grow up lower middle class
it's just not it seems like you keep
hearing the phrase pipe dream it's a
pipe dream you know this
and and my mother who i guess in her
youth probably had
creative aspirations and had a good
voice and um you know so she was kind of
living through me and so she was very
much in support
in support of it but my dad who's very
reserved everybody comes around once you
start having success and you know and
then one of the great fulfilling full
circle elements to that is when i got to
do flags of our fathers with clint
eastwood oh my god he must have flipped
out that's the only person my dad cares
about
yeah that's
like you know he grew up idolizing like
or whatever like and so two of my
greatest moments that i feel like i
provided or was part of providing for my
father well yeah i did provide was um
him getting to meet clint eastwood
and him getting to hold the lombardi
trophy that after the eagles ones oh my
god those are two things that no one can
ever take away you know how did you get
your hands in the lombardi trophy you
were partying with those guys you were
like right no no no so this was after
the super bowl win um i'm like somewhat
friendly with the owner and with some of
the people in the organization and after
the super bowl they take the trophy to
the team facilities and then there was
this period of time before it's sent
away to be engraved and they invited me
and my son and i brought my father and
we all went up to the nova care facility
where the eagles practiced that's cool
and got to take pictures holding the
lombardi trophy which you know is the
first one for the eagles ever yeah you
know oh my god that was it's such a
great game it was and and to wait that
long and i i really think my dad thought
he was going to die before seeing an
eagle super bowl you know so i i i
treasure that
[Music]
this weekend was very fun for us we got
to uh put our movie out into the world
lady the manor but it was a little
stressful it's a strange feeling being
that vulnerable and having people watch
the thing that you worked so hard on and
so i was having some trouble sleeping
what did i do i
cracked open well i twisted open the top
of my plus cbd
daily use of plus cbd sleep gum is gets
you the rest you need so you can wake up
feeling focused and refreshed and
it's formulated by a team of medical
experts and doctors so you know it's
good plus cbd sleep gummies taste great
and they're made up of award-winning cbd
combined with melatonin
magnolia bark which i've tried to chew
straight from the tree and it is not
easy and you look foolish yeah yeah oh
my god people yeah somebody took a
picture of me doing it i pretended i was
doing a bit but uh and it's so there's
also lemon balm in there which is also
not the best thing to try to eat on its
own so if you want to sleep better
tonight just do this visit plus cbd oil
dot com and enter promo code long for 40
off your order that's code long at plus
c b d oil dot com for forty percent off
that's a lot forty percent all plus cbd
products are third party tested fully
traceable from seed to shelf so you can
be assured you're getting the highest
quality hemp cbd
hello hello
we'll meet again
[Music]
clint eastwood must be
really used to this i mean like he must
be used to specifically like actors he's
working with uh their their fathers
specifically i don't want to like i hope
that doesn't sound sexist but i know
women like things
but like it must oh yes they do i've
seen it
i've seen it he's and he's just kind of
like a ch he's like a i got friends who
worked with him is he he's just a hard
worker steely guy but he's funny right
isn't he like surprisingly very funny
yeah and really self-deprecating man
like he'll he'll make jokes about
himself
society you know the just the the world
like i you know i had a quite a few like
personal or private conversations with
me where he would say he would
he would never want to be any young
actor in this day and age he's like you
don't know the stuff that i used to get
away with nobody does he's like you
can't get away with anything now you
know like um
i mean i feel that a little bit i know
some of the interviews i had this
morning what came up during because
press interviews it's just again it goes
back to just being awkward and you're
always afraid that you're gonna you're
gonna misspeak or this or that
and then also the repetitive nature of
it which i you know very well where they
somehow completely you know individuals
in far-off places who have never met
each other somehow arrive at the same
four goddamn questions or whatever it is
but so one that kept coming up today and
it also makes you feel like a dinosaur
is like what advice would you give to
young actors coming up today
it's like i don't know like
like good luck i guess i don't know like
so much of the onus is placed on this
social media presence and this constant
need to put out content or to feel like
i it seems exhausting to me
like to wake up and have that be at the
fore of your mind or dictate your day is
like your posts and your little you know
dancing and the tick tock i don't i
still don't get it man i don't i just
don't it all it is is people dancing to
songs like
in various like i just i know and lip
syncing and stuff i don't understand i
know we sound old uh i know that what
would you tell young people who um who
wrestle with it who grow up with that
that's just the reality of how
um actors promote themselves now i have
a friend he's [ __ ] funny and great
and like strange and but he is the the
last person that i would have thought
would get instagram and he just got it
and he's
he's struggling with it i know but
that's kind of part of the world now
it's it's just so antithetical to who he
is you know his nature his nature is
being compromised um what would you say
to young people who grow up in this i
mean you have a son uh
who grew up in this reality uh how which
how what advice would you give him or
even yourself to balance
that yeah i mean with the kids
thankfully i mean my kids are they're on
social media but they're not
wrapped up but it doesn't it's not their
life you know
even like you know my son who's with me
all the time right now
he's working on his music career and he
spends so much more time focused on
actually making music and you know he
checks his phone and he interacts with
friends through it but i i haven't had
to govern it too much with him and also
because they've grown up with parents in
the public eye they understand the
potential dangers and the fact that none
of this stuff is ever really deleted it
can all be used you know
against you depending on what it is or
depending on a person's reaction
it could really change the trajectory of
your life
if you post or print or publish the
wrong thing and that's that's what i've
made you know a point of of distinction
for them is that when you when you write
a tweet and send it out you are
essentially publishing something for the
world and for the world's consumption
now you might have a small follower base
or whatever it is but if it gets picked
up or if it's interpreted in such a way
that thing goes viral even if you're a
nobody there's a
lack of responsibility at least in the
beginning with social media people were
just firing off whatever they wanted but
like you have to understand like that
it's permanent and it's published and
it's like thinking about it in those
terms will definitely change what you
put out in the world i totally i always
think about that it's to in terms of
twitter specifically um if a funny thing
pops into my head or if i have that
thought and i've had it a few times not
often but i think oh that'd be funny to
tweet
i never do it because i i always um
i second-guess it or i i worry about how
it's how it'll be received it's just too
much it requires too much mental thought
it's it's not worth the the whatever
thought that popped into your head it's
no longer just a fun thought it becomes
a point of concern
it's just not worth it yeah it can it
can yeah and i think too this is
something that i've been talking with
people a lot about is that like
you know the things that that uh
musicians or rappers or out-and-out
comedians can get away with saying we
cannot like even though you're primarily
known as a comedic actor it's still
like
but like and and that's a thing to me
that i find confusing sometimes it's
like you could make a a wild joke and it
could be received in a in a much
different way than if comedian x or does
it right like it's like it's just not
worth it no it's just not it's not worth
your time not to say i mean i like that
this is maybe this is just our excuse
for not having anything funny to say
really
it's not worth it i have all these great
tweets but i'm not good
yeah well i don't want to get in trouble
but but yours your kids almost also must
did it give them pause having grown up
um
with the two of you did it give them
pause in terms of even going into
some entertainment field
like like music even i mean was that
was that a concern for them see because
they they saw the reality of two
successful actors
um and the paparazzi and all that must
have been
that they got to see all the negative
[ __ ] yeah did that give them concern or
pause
for my daughter maybe a little more so
my son tends to take things more in
stride and i think that
you know a lot of that stuff has calmed
down like the way the paparazzi were in
the late 90s early 2000s oh yeah
people don't remember really unless you
were living in it or through it but like
they were going through our trash they
were climbing over the fence in the
backyard when reece and i had our first
child that was such a big deal they
would they would stop at nothing like it
was really
there were moments of that were really
creepy really unsettling um and now
what do you do ryan i mean if you i
can't imagine what i would do if i saw
somebody going through my trash do you
call the police dude i've gone after a
few of them you know there are a couple
times that almost became physical
altercations that i'm sure i would have
been sued for or gotten yeah because
there was this period of time too where
the paparazzi would goad you into some
kind of a response
you know that this happened with quite a
few people and and like it became a
known thing because you know yes i could
get this amount of money for a
photograph but i can get even more if
you touch me if you if you if you come
after me physically or whatever it is
yeah they would say awful things yeah
and really like things that that in the
real world
a fraction of that kind of stuff would
lead to a fist fight or some sort of
like violent altercation but there's the
constant threat of being sued they also
know all the rules they know how to
extract money they're really uh
predatory right but but now with the
advent of social media and everybody
sharing their lives of their own
volition it's taken the price the bounty
has gone way down they just don't make
you know there's a thousand celebrity
blog spots where you know back in the
late 90s there was like two or three
entertainment magazines that paid a
premium for those photographs now
everyone publishes and puts out you know
their whole life they everybody lives
online and shows everything now anyway
so they just don't get the same
it's not the same value uh proposition
for paparazzi whatever exists of that
the remnants of that paparazzi culture
now do you think it is because of that
because of what you just said is it even
more sinister i mean is it even more
is there a more nefarious agenda behind
it is it now to get you
in an uncompromising situation or yeah
yeah or looking like [ __ ] or like your
nose or like
yes yeah yeah because that is the only
way
that their work is now still sensational
or relevant yeah because like i said
it's like everybody's posting their
outfit so you know you're going to go
out later and attend event an event in
that outfit but you've already put on
instagram your hot dress yeah whatever
you know like when you borrow
awarenesses well
thanks what was the psychological
journey for you
with that kind of stuff i mean how do
you i did not handle it well in the
beginning am i in my early 20s and in
defense or protection of my young my fat
young family i did not handle it well at
all man like it would get my blood
boiling i would see red i would like i
would just want it you know it's like a
like a
a bear you want to protect your your
family and that sort of thing but then
you can't you probably are then aware of
that reaction in front of your kids so
then how do you
how do you calibrate that how do you how
do you not have that response i mean
it's just you evolve it's yeah it takes
uh learning and patience and
understanding and um and and just not
reacting um yeah
on your first instinct you know um
but uh yeah there were some times
yeah i bet i i went back to clinton for
a second because now i'm thinking about
like what he would do how he responds to
things like that what did you learn from
him and what was that experience like i
i want to hear about like your dad's
interaction with him too how
how great was that well that was really
brief and that was at the premiere you
know and so that was kind of like a
handshake and a nice to meet you and you
know i think uh clint told my dad thank
you for serving and that kind of thing
and that was really brief but just the
look on his face and and okay you know
it's something that i'll always remember
but the experience of working with him
um
you know similar to working with altman
the two of them
even though their careers are so
different um had very similar approaches
to filmmaking very economical efficient
um the set is is is is like peaceful he
clinton doesn't like anybody yelling you
know he doesn't scream action instead he
just goes go ahead you know it's like
it's like you know and also like the
the one take thing is so fascinating and
so interesting and so freeing in some
ways because you know right if if we do
a scene
and you do you know eight takes of my
close-up
i may
be
relatively happy with one or two of them
but at the end of the day i'm gonna come
home and i'm gonna think about all eight
and like oh i wish you that part of that
part or i could have done this here and
there's something more like doing a play
when you do one take it's like well we
did it you know it's like and if it's
okay with him
who am i to argue you know it's like if
if he feels like he got it then you have
to submit to
[Music]
the way
he works and and you know some people
that's not easy to do like there was
people i saw in in the film i did with
him people resisting that or asking for
one more and he would say
you go ahead and do one more i'm gonna
move on
and you're my god oh my god
that's wild when would he do one more
ride like if he were to do one more you
you know that's something either
technical happening it was technical
usually because he he likes the the
vitality of the first take and he likes
imperfections he doesn't like actors
having long enough to start to act to
start to
to uh perform you know um that's a big
thing for him it's like i think he feels
like the longer
you give an actor with a specific scene
or or a certain amount of takes it
starts to be it gets further away from
what he perceives as the truth
that's interesting
that makes sense
but then but there's no rehearsal though
right i mean like no no and in fact on
that movie i played in navy corpsman
so i was a medic you know a field medic
in the war and
nobody told me
anything about being a medic i had to go
and do all of that research on my own
they did end up putting me with the guy
who had served and
and and and was but um i had to do most
of the research you're expected to do
most of that research all the technical
stuff all the like actually say helping
somebody out in the field well when it
got down to the detail like okay this
time you are you're putting a tourniquet
on someone i would have an advisor there
to work with me
you know and i i remember i took a dummy
back to my hotel room and i would do
various like bandages and and so i would
work on the dummy and in my in my off
hours but yeah like there it's
when people like that
cast you in a film they're expecting you
to come prepared and to deliver that's
both flattering and probably terrifying
really terrifying yeah yeah
were there were there takes where you
were like i did not get it what is he
talking about i i [ __ ] up the line i
whatever no i mean i
there were a couple of people i talked
to before i worked with him one of them
was tim robbins who had worked with him
on mystic river
um
uh lawrence fishburne i talked to also
and um i kind of knew what i was going
into and i just started to approach it
like like a theatrical performance like
a play yeah and you you you don't get
multiple takes in a play yeah you have
to know your lines you have to know your
character and you have to
say and do what you're supposed to at
the right time in a play that's it
you know and then after that and there
was some like i was saying there was
some kind of release or freedom in that
it's like
i'm sure you can put everything into
them just psychologically i'm trying to
like you put everything into that you
know that it's uh
it's all going to be left out there
there must be something kind of
liberating about that too yeah and and
exciting yeah it was like when when
i got to host snl which was one of the
craziest experiences of my life and
you know it's the closest thing to an
athletic event for an actor you know
you're being dragged in between scenes
someone's dressing you while you're
being moved to the next set you know the
but but being in the moment like that
and feeling that kind of pressure
is is adrenalizing it's kind of like
addicting too like and and you know and
also with the eastwood movie this was
like a 100 million dollar budget
i remember one time we were on the beach
in iceland that was meant to be iwo jima
and i looked to my left and there's
literally 500 extras holding weapons to
my my left
and you kind of lose yourself in the
moment and still that sequence is one
take you know unless oh my unless the
mortar doesn't properly fire or one of
the pyrotechnics doesn't go off
it's like all of that equipment all that
personnel and you're still just gonna do
it one time is really
really crazy well it's something like
that you must choreograph the [ __ ] out
of it you must rehearse that right like
with the camera and stuff man not really
not too much i mean there's like a
walk-through with steadicam there was a
walk-through with steadicam but nothing
nothing no not really that's and somehow
everyone rises to the occasion and you
know he's he's got such a system going
on where
um
a lot of his crew have worked with him
have met and married on his films have
had children you know they've been with
him for decades so it runs like a
well-oiled machine man it's like there's
no drop-off they know exactly what he
wants and needs it's like everyone it's
beyond a shorthand it's like almost like
a no hand which was you know like
there was something nice about you and
christian had a dynamic like that where
you guys like there there was there was
the handoff like between the two of you
and and you know your your thoughts and
approaches to the scenes and obviously
so much of your personalities and humor
is in the script and um
which was intimidating or overt
masculinity
yeah i bet i
but well you really like played it very
cool uh i i think ryan that's the first
time we've ever been compared in any way
to the music well there you go
uh no was there anything on snl that
when you pitched your um ideas and stuff
was there anything that you pitched that
you were
really dying to do that they did that
they like or like an impression that you
wanted to do dude i had like a whole
booklet
of p of pitch ideas i i i've been
writing down for weeks leading up and
things that i thought i could be good at
and i thought would be funny and when it
came to the day i that notebook never
got opened in the room
i was so
i was so
intimidated or whatever it was that like
i
i also i didn't know you know because
somebody who's not from comedy and that
sort of thing if they would even be
receptive or listen to my ideas like
that yeah so i had all of these good
ideas that i just never even offered up
because i got too scared
uh-huh yeah i bet it's different when
you're there in the room and lorne
michaels is there and these people that
you admire these comedians are there
pitching you ideas um
was clint what is what did he first say
to you when he cast you though like how
does somebody like that say i want you
to do this like what was it about do you
ever articulate that i never met him
until we were on the private plane
waiting to fly to washington dc to shoot
at the iwo jima memorial that was the
first time i ever met him so i had been
i had been put on tape
like four or five times for various
roles and then was cass
and the first time i ever laid eyes on
him in person was jesse and brett jesse
bradford and i were on the plane the
warner brothers plane waiting on the
tarmac and we see this black suv pull up
and clink gets out and gets on the plane
and he's like hey nice to meet you that
was the first time i ever met him
what do you say or do you call him mr
eastwood yeah
yeah very much until yeah i think later
on because then you know we got close
enough that like after the movie he came
to my house and played piano and stuff
so i think we we did get to a place
where i could call him clint but i'm
always super respectful anyway i was
just raised like yeah yeah mindful of
manners and now i know you kept calling
me mr mong and christian mr long it
became confusing because we didn't know
which of us you were talking about just
who i am it's just how it was raised uh
people would be so mad if i didn't ask
about cruel intentions um movies like
that i know you did last summer croons
that must have changed you were like
heartthrob status people you were in the
public consciousness
what was it like and how different do
you think it is today i don't know i
mean i got cast in in i know what you
did last summer that was like a really
sought-after uh project at the time like
everybody around yeah this age wanted to
be in that and like and so i went
through like a you know multiple
auditions to be in that and then as
we're making i know what you did last
summer the same producers had the script
for cool intentions
and
so they shared it with sarah michelle
and i um
while we were shooting i know what you
did last summer and i was like
my parents will be so mad if i do this
movie about cruel intentions because
it's it's a very
racy like
even still man like it's like it's still
it's very much an envelope pushing teen
movie it's true there's some racy [ __ ]
in there
in fact maybe even more now
yeah to watch maybe yeah i mean it's
like you know we look back at so many
things through the lens of today and
we're like oh would this even be made or
would you know oh no um but at the same
time it was it was so darkly funny and
it was so biting and like it was my
sense of humor you know and so i was i
was dying to do it but
even in accepting that role or or or the
reception of that movie after i was
never really cognizant or
or
intent on it launching me into like
heartthrob status or whatever i just
never saw myself that way i still don't
i never you know i'm
incredibly insecure all that sort of
stuff and it's it's through
the the allowance of losing myself in a
character that i can really appreciate
what i do honestly you know and it's
like that's what was fun about playing
tanner too similarly is like to play
someone who's so far from you and that
you gives you like this license you know
a lot of times when you have to be the
leading guy
and you you're the protagonist there's
so many rules unspoken rules that come
along with that about behavior and you
know you've got to be the person
everybody identifies with and the strong
archetype or whatever but it's fun to
inhabit these other characters who who
don't give a [ __ ] who don't have any
self-awareness who you know
or in tanner's case is like the poster
boy for arrested development like you
know hasn't grown beyond his college
years you know even though it's well
it's an extension of sebastian a little
bit it's it there was an element of
sebastian which i it's funny like that
movie was so indelible to me but i never
considered it maybe because you were
seen in this light i saw you in this
light as like
uh heartthrob got it but you were
playing against your own natural like
you said your own natural personality
but at the time it was just it was such
a good performance that i
there may have even been a part of me
that thought oh that's kind of like what
he's like a little bit but i didn't
realize what a character part of it was
i got that reaction a lot too um from
from people throughout the years and uh
you know it's it's it's funny
no it but it but it's but it's also kind
of a compliment because like i said i
grew up lower middle class you know
terrible education nobody had money like
you know and then then for people to
believe that i was this person that came
from wealth and like was you know
like i feel like okay i did my it's true
it's true i know you really i would
never i guess i always made those
discussions about you
uh because of how good the performance
was
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello
again we'll meet
[Music]
there's so much again but i know you
gotta go soon so i i gotta do this
lightning round okay which i'm i'm so
curious about uh
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to emoji uh i
think the prayer hands if you could be a
professional athlete i think i know this
what sport would you play it'd be
football yeah did you play in high
school no my high school i didn't have a
football i played soccer they didn't
have a football program it was very a
very underfunded christian school
yeah yeah but no i just i love football
i love it it's it you know i sometimes i
deal i struggle a lot with my depression
and mental health and sometimes like
sometimes i feel like football is the
only thing that can hold my attention
like live sports and the nature of it of
it being like you know unpredictable um
i sometimes if i get in in bad states
i find it very difficult to watch like
narrative tv or movies i get that yeah
and like it's and then it becomes for me
like podcasts work for me in those when
i'm in those spaces and live sports and
and football and basketball are the only
two that i really watch and
i i just i love football and does
exercise help that i mean you you were
so in such good shape yeah what's your
go-to exercise do you still do martial
arts um i'll practice on my own and you
know if i have to get ready for a part
that requires it obviously i'll train
then but um
yeah the the commitment to exercising
five or six days a week is largely about
reduction of stress and anxiety and and
and feeling like
that's therapy for me if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be
not a big snacker oh really not really
not really but i tend to if i'm going to
go towards something it's it's boring
it's like either chips or pretzels
um i like those pretzel fins those yeah
those are great yeah with these so good
that's the best one yes when is mcgruber
coming out by the way is it coming out
soon christmas
oh god i'm very magruber christmas what
was the movie that you wanted to
introduce your kids to that that was
really special to you growing up um that
you were really excited to show your
kids i remember well star wars is kind
of like the easy one in some ways um et
was one
and then i watched the goonies with my
kids and they loved it and i was afraid
they wouldn't like it i see that's what
i worry about because i want to i worry
that like something like that something
beloved to you you show them and they're
like by the way why did they never do a
remake or a sequel to the goonies it's
so crazy didn't they talk about it for
years i remember hearing that yeah it's
always been in the ether but it just
never happened it's so strange uh yeah
so funny we were talking seth green was
on i have to have brecken on uh it so
makes sense that you're friends with
those guys it's uh yeah i was just with
brecken last night
oh really yeah do you still do the
dantanas thing yeah we yeah well now
it's at craigs but yeah oh yeah same
group and we're you know we're probably
like at like
700
plus dinners
oh my god that's wild yeah it's really
crazy tell him i say hi uh [ __ ] man we i
know we gotta go what's your go-to
karaoke song
probably
big pimpin
by jay-z
i would love to see that uh who was your
first celebrity crush uh olivia newton
john okay greece yeah
yeah she just did it for me on every
level
yeah that makes it yeah you're very
confident about that uh if you had to
get another tattoo
what would you get and where are you
gonna get more i think i'd probably
start erasing them
well i've already i i have covered a
couple that like were were that that
that i got um in tribute to either women
i dated or whatever it was and then you
know it didn't work and so you had to
get rid of those but also you make a lot
of rash decisions when you're young and
like you know
and then you get to a certain age like
why the hell do i have this on my body
yeah you know
i like
i heard like pete davidson is starting
to remove some of his and i'm like all
right i'm gonna kind of hit him up and
ask him how that's going i heard it's
really painful and it takes so many
treatments that's what i heard but
yeah i i don't know that i'll get any
more unless i completely quit acting
it's a pain in the ass to cover them it
just is
well i know yeah but we had to deal with
that yeah i bet especially for i mean
how do you it must take hours in the
makeup chair because you have a sleeve
now actually there's a new product out
that we use just use i just use for the
first time a macgruber and we did the
whole sleeve my arm in 25 minutes oh no
kidding okay and it looked better than
before when they used to do the air
brushing and this is a way simpler
process it's just a different makeup
that's made specifically now people are
designing stuff specifically to make it
easier oh wow what's your favorite fruit
probably
peach a peach yeah yeah
right okay hearts beat
it's great i i've been uh
denying peaches for nectarines like
where i live um
they're just there's like the two-week
window where they're when they're ripe
they're
on another level uh and they put a peach
to shame but usually i'd agree with you
uh who do you want to play you in your
biopic in the rhine philippi
feel epic i mean
just one of those tick tock kids just
whoever
[Music]
just grab a grab a social media
sensation and who do who do people
usually confuse you with who do they
usually get wrong you're like oh dude
you're so-and-so i don't know they used
to say
used to be justin timberlake or vice
versa
um
i don't know not too many though i
haven't had that a whole lot
yeah
do you
uh
you're the i've gotten flattering ones
like sometimes it's keanu reeves that's
a really flattering one for me yeah uh
sometimes it's david schwimmer um
[Music]
not so much anymore uh
who who's your favorite muppet
animal
uh-huh
do you play instruments do you play the
drums i don't play the drums i can play
a little bit of piano but nothing that i
would
advertise
so you wouldn't even mention it it's not
even working no
what is your go-to pizza topping
pepperoni green pepper and mushroom
okay i i asked stanley tucci this
yesterday and he said um
nothing
nothing of course he did
so pure just such a minimalist
uh yeah
um passing touch
dogs your cat stupid bird dogs
um beetles the rolling stones if you
could pick i mean i guess
i guess i'm gonna go beetles is there a
song that um if you're in a bar right
now they have a jukebox what what what
beetle song you put on right now would
you want to hear well actually
i mean i was such a fan of lennon's solo
career after and songs like watching the
wheels and
um
and so that's why when i choose the
beatles answer i'm thinking more about
the individuals in the group like i'm
thinking about lenin yeah
um
you know and and yeah the stones you can
have you have keith and mick i don't
know there's just um there was something
more tortured and soulful about lenin
especially post beetles that i think i
just is this i'm so connected to uh dude
i could talk to you for hours this sucks
i know you have to go that's all right
uh but this is the best and i can't
thank you enough we're gonna sing your
praises more
on the outro um thank you but man i you
know you know how i feel about you i uh
i miss you i can't wait to hang yeah
let's hang and i loved working with you
and i'm excited now that the movie's out
in the world and i hope people have a
good time watching it and let's do it
again
[Music]
so
so that
it was it grossed the way i was doing it
it was just so funny that we like knew
that we were gonna do that i got excited
so so that happened so that so that
happened so that happened
um i think i did my impression of ryan
for him um you know who does an
incredible one i mine comes from max
miguela the actor max mcallister
incredible
wonderful impression um i hope he's
listening but it's it's sort of like
it's you have to make your lips as
because ryan has naturally very pillowy
lips so i wanted you to take that one
they're
supple and uh all right
well would i only know they were supple
if i've touched them
i think that's a touch sensation somehow
you can i think you can say they look
like they would be supple yes well we
shouldn't be saying either really
because
um ryan is a friend of ours and uh i
don't want him to be thinking that now
when we socialize next
but i do catch myself looking at his
lips hopefully he doesn't listen to this
when you ask what his uh favorite fruit
was and he goes probably peach
yes i know and then you mentioned for
like the thirteenth oh i
i gotta stop oh my god i know it's like
okay i know but i did taste them they
are i get why you talk about them right
it's really delicious it's like that
seinfeld episode the mackinaw peaches
episode it is like oh my god i mean they
really like i i also had them when i was
stoned you know somebody on instagram
because i've been i posted about the
movie and somebody was like the biggest
surprise of the day was that you smoke
you get stoned really yeah and i
i don't know why i wasn't offended but i
was like well i'm so it's funny that
somebody could have that kind of
perception of me that i i'm like such a
square i can kind of see that yeah i
guess i can too especially if you've
only seen you in a certain role yeah and
like playing nerds
but nerds now even smoke i mean that
used to be whatever i'm going off trying
also funny when he said um which i
didn't know he was so into taekwondo
that's cool that he was like gonna be a
professional i didn't know that i i knew
that he posted about every once in a
while where he does he's like i wanted
to start my own dojo it's fun
say dojo yeah dojo go joe um yeah i know
he i and like
again not surprising he's like an
incredible shape yeah yeah it's also not
surprising that he
he's gonna he's gonna be like guys calm
down
i don't know if we can hang out socially
if we go go on like this about him but
um he's in great shape and
also for like he's 45 years old i think
that's crazy it's crazy but we shouldn't
talk about go on about his looks because
this is also not a uh but i like his
tattoo regrets too i know like what
tattoo he's like what tattoo would i get
rid of at this point it's funny because
when we were doing like in the manor uh
there was a moment i think it ended up
lending itself to the character and
being for the best but we we had a
moment of panic when we saw him and he
told us about his sleeve of tattoos he
also had uh a thigh of tattoos that he
couldn't because he was supposed to take
his pants off remember that scene and so
we had to shoot it from boiler alert
spoiler alert well it's but that might
be a good spoiler for people to get into
this oh that's true that's the eyeballs
on the movie yes yeah if we promise
philippe flesch
fill a flesh um
philippe you know
um but it's
he it must be annoying and i remember
the makeup and we didn't have enough we
have time it was a lo like we can't stop
talking about how low budget it was but
we just didn't have the luxury of like
covering up those tattoos but that was
and we were shooting in florida so it
was really hot yeah
yeah so it was like the option was
either
take three hours every day to cover up
all his tattoos which we didn't have
time for or put them in like salmon
colored blazers
was great it looked i think it was a
really funny like you said character
choice i do too and um he he was really
into that and he got really involved in
that but it was also like yeah boiling
hot i mean he must he was always and
never again never complained
never showed any signs of i remember
checking in with him a bunch of times
like um you know are you okay especially
some of the bigger the crowd scene
spoiler alert there are crowd scenes but
um
you know where he would just kind of be
waiting uh along with everyone else also
a big part of that was our fault that we
didn't plan things as well as we should
have so there was a lot of um it wasn't
as organized you know it's our first
movie yeah give us a break yeah uh
blowing pains but um as a result there
was a lot of
waiting around for him and
for someone of his caliber
and his resume
to spend a lot of time in costume just
waiting around on set
like a lot of time like hours and hours
without even a hint of
complaining never in fact like i
couldn't get over i was like i admired
his
like
teamwork i know i don't know what the
right word is it's like gaminess that's
the kind of thing you would so much you
would never know that unt until you were
there in the trenches with somebody like
that and it speaks to how he was raised
um how not the opposite of that cruel
intentions character he really is yeah
that i think that is it really was an
indelible performance that's my big like
biggest takeaway from
knowing him a little bit and your
conversation with him listening to it is
that i think that specifically that
performance and cruel intentions which
is like iconic
um
was so so good and the movie was so good
that it really affected the way people
saw him as a person because and part of
it was that
you know like not to beat a dead horse
but he's he's so handsome
and that he that he also came across as
like this very like society kid well to
do
but it's so different than who he is as
a person like a lower middle class kid
growing up in delaware who was insecure
i'm obsessed with saturday night live i
know i went to a christian high school
it's like almost the opposite for like a
talent show almost the opposite of that
character totally but yet
and myself included i think so many
people
um started seeing him that way and i
like i've i know i've said this on the
show so many times but
my perception of someone has so often
been
incorrect and then you hear that you
hear from them you get to know them a
little bit and you realize that oh my
god i like had a totally different idea
of this person you know and no one more
than him me too your perception of ryan
phillippe doesn't have to have changed
i've haven't gotten to know him
but um i'm so glad i got to know him and
and
i because we were even like
in no way hesitant to cast him we we
felt very right off the bat like once we
heard he was interested we were very
fortunate but um i don't i had no idea
he would be as easy and game and like as
different from
how i imagined i didn't either but
that's that's on me because oh yeah me
too no right to think that until i
pre-judge him like i saw him in some
movies and i i knew about his like
tabloid like who he was married to
people do that a lot project of course
of course i but it it's not it's not
fair and like him talking about the way
that was crazy that paparazzi treated
them back in the day
i can't imagine i mean i can a little
bit i mean i had a taste of that and
like they were you know they the you
kind of remember that back in the way
they would drive through i mean
i mean like really scary dangerous stuff
driving through red lights and stuff and
i i remember hearing cars slam on the
brakes and like car horns behind us when
we were trying to get rid of
them yeah i mean they were it's scary
um but but he must have had it like 10
times because he was you know
and and again like for somebody who is
and also protective of his family i
don't know what that's like at all
thanks no no
i didn't mean that i mean with papa
i don't know what as i took cabbie he
seemed to care for his family members um
him talking about mcgruber was really
interesting because
one i think that he had that impulse to
try to be funny when he first i know
and he also had the honesty to admit
that he was trying to be funny yeah and
he had the ability to
uh put his ego in check and not be funny
once he got that direction right and
just play it totally straight and not
and not try to steal scenes or anything
and as a result that
movie and i'm sure the show i can't wait
for the show i know it works so well i
mean obviously in part because front of
the show will forte and hopefully future
friend of the show chris and wake by the
way i think ryan philby is like
that
he makes that movie oh yeah i mean
playing it straight and and committing
to playing it like it's just an action
movie i know that's that's what makes it
so funny i know those guys were so smart
to do that to really like and like shun
all the like big comedy stars who want
to be in the series i know it's kind of
cool it's really cool and they were i
mean that takes some nerve that takes
some guts to do that and to commit to
that in fact i remember seeing that
movie in the theater i was so excited to
see it um and i remember thinking like
wow i'm surprised ryan phillip philippe
did this you know like his because he
was such a big and i saw him in such a
different light uh prior to that and so
it's sort of at first when he told me
that about his agents i was like huh my
instinct was to
be surprised at the agents and how and
and their how little
um
how little vision they had but i
remember thinking that at the time too
like i'm surprised he did this movie was
ryan phillippe playing this like
this
kind of throwaway not throwaway but like
a very procedural part it's kind of a
kind of like this boring part
but he it takes
guts to do that and to commit to it and
it takes somebody because it's also not
a boring part when you not at all play
it straight i mean that's the lesson
right not at all but at the time boring
is the wrong word um
not flashy
and it's it takes a lot of confidence to
play a part like that and and it takes i
think a true understanding of the comedy
it's it's like something you see in
waiting for government you know there
are moments like that in waiting for
government or any of those christopher
guest movies where
those actors are playing it so real that
it's like if you read it in a script if
there's a script of goffman which was an
all-improv movie it probably wouldn't
read as very funny right
i mean him comparing in any way magruber
to like the awkward moments the
awkwardness of magruber 2 our movie is
like i think it's so flattering i mean
mcgruber is
like obviously didn't like he talked
about did not do well it was bombed in
fact when it came out and was like
critics hated it critics hated it but
now it's uh it's it's a classic hey
that's a nice thing to think about yeah
that's something to uh
because comedy is i mean that's what
we've been learning the last couple of
days that's really been hitting home for
us
how subjective it is and certainly when
it comes to like a critic who doesn't
like the movie it's
it's purely about if you find something
funny
it's been um it's been interesting and
like it's been a lesson in setting our
own expectations aside too uh
and and reminding ourselves that like
hey we find it funny and so again we
hope you find it funny at the end of the
day that's all you can do right exactly
and you know we think about some like
comedies that inspired us like some some
of the early adam sandler comedies or or
um you know what about bob we've talked
about uh and those movies typically
don't aren't beloved by critics so
i don't know it helps to remember that
for us for our own little fragile egos
should we read a letter yes let me go
all right let me rephrase should you
read a letter okay yeah i was gonna say
like well you want to read all of a
sudden you don't get to read that with
the ac going on are you hot
yeah did i have my little mustache what
do i i think i might i can't a little
bit yeah you both have that much sweat
when it gets too hot in a room with no
ventilation okay this is for whoa
this is from mayor michelle
you know i've been thinking about the
name i love mayor winningham so much the
actress the actress well both mayor is a
cool name but the actress i love and um
i just saw this great val kilmer
documentary that he made that about his
life it's really amazing but i didn't
know that they they dated they were uh
lovers hmm i didn't know anything yeah
marin val too great what a great you're
such a gossip well i didn't mean that
that's true
yeah what a weird thing to point out
from that it's a really like
life-affirming documentary too and
that's what i took from it but they did
i didn't know they were lovers
um why does a gossip person sound like
that
jim gaffigan
oh geez he's doing different voices now
um
okay subject from mayor michelle
sounds like mayor of michelle i thought
that's what you said at first that's
mayor m-a-r-e mayor michelle cool that
might be a confusing name to have mayor
subject blast from the past hi guys i
hope you're well and got to do something
really i'm sorry
yeah hi guys i hope you are well and got
to do something you really enjoyed today
oh well we're doing this yeah so yeah
we do we are uh i wanted to thank you
for creating such a wonderful podcast i
discovered it after watching your
episode of celebrity family feud oh boy
still still laughing at christian's
necklace answer oh boy isn't that crazy
that your shame is
public whenever i see my friend chris
now he always goes necklace i know i saw
him do that i didn't realize when he did
that in the video why he that's funny he
thinks that's the funniest thing it's
funny and so does mayor yeah
um well mayor in my defense oh
it's a little nerve-wracking to be on
family feud with steve harvey right next
to you and a lot of money on the line
for charity so uh
i panicked that's fair and i gave a
really dumb answer that's mayor
um
okay i've uh i've been it is and yeah i
get it i was really nervous
it's it's there's like you know what we
want yeah yeah happy ending okay
and if we had lost whatever it would
have been funny much less happiness yes
that's true because we probably would
have lost because of necklace
um i've been binge listening since
episode number one and just finished the
allison brie episode thank you mayor
life is short has been helping me get
through my days at work and is such a
joy to listen to before bed really nice
to hear
since i'm starting from the beginning i
got to hear the transition from
pre-covered times the state in which the
world is in now my heart breaks for the
two of us
and my heart breaks for the two of us as
i listen to the past versions of
yourselves gush over your grandmother
knowing in present day she's already
passed on yeah
yeah that'd be
i gotta re-listen to that episode one
day not quite ready you see i lost my
grandmother to covet in may uh may 2020
and i feel as though i never got to
properly mourn her
the world was shut down when we lost her
so it still feels like i'll see her
again
once the world goes back to normal yeah
i bet yeah i've been feeling that you
know it's weird because i have such
memories of her in the summertime she
would come visit my grandmother come
visit the summer and this past summer
was strange um
i'm sorry if you're lost yeah i i i mean
like you said we're going through it
still and yeah you know i had a moment
started interrupt uh watching the movie
and um
and the first on the big screen on
opening night and i thought oh man it
would be
it'd be so cool if graham was still
alive to see this but that might like
immediately i had another thought which
is
she
i wouldn't want her to see this movie
yeah and and like i know because she was
like the most supportive person
ever
she like 100 would have seen it
and uh and it's
some of that humor no i know some of the
more crass elements of the movie yeah i
would have felt very uncomfortable if
uh you know subjecting her to that me
too i thought the same thing yeah you
don't both have to think that you're
glad that your grandmother can't see
this but would have loved for her to be
there um i know me too but you know why
because you know because like we kind of
shoehorned some uh pretty spicy
comedic stuff into
uh sort of fluffy sweet buddy comedy
like um and so she she might have been
confused it's like
oh there are certain elements she would
have been like really into i think you
know like oh that's cute and like the
two of them have to work together to do
this yeah but that's like i know i mean
hopefully she wouldn't be able to hear
it very well that's what she had really
bad hearing at the end and
wouldn't let anyone get her a good
hearing aid because she felt guilt about
people spending money on her and i can
attest to this specifically specifically
to that because she came to see a movie
i did at the fort lauderdale film
festival um a year before she passed
away and um it was she was so sweet to
come and like
she came with her friend winnie shout
out and she just was having a hard i had
to kind of it was funny because i had
she's what and she wanted to hear it so
i was like having to kind of say what i
was saying on the screen just like into
her ear
this is so such a fun night anyway i'm
sorry mayor um
yeah so she's back to mayor she said so
many people like myself never got to say
goodbye i mourn your loss the way i
never got to mourn mine sending you all
the biggest hugs what a nice what a nice
thing to hear thank you
um and and likewise on a lighter note i
do have some would you rather questions
that i hope you'll enjoy
exciting
number one would you rather create your
life's greatest work and have no one see
it
or be famous for only making terrible
mediocre movies
to be clear the amazing ones that
already exist don't in this scenario
that is such a good question that is so
timely it is i see hmm
that's really tricky because yeah
my instinct was to say the first one art
and ego
i would pick the second one
not because i want to be famous for
anything
but because it would imply that
uh
you're working and you have a live
working
and you have a livelihood whereas the
first one
if no one sees it
then it doesn't
really count as
making something for me because part of
it for someone
you want to make it for something and i
would say a lesson that i've learned
this weekend is that um
[Music]
comedy especially is very subjective a
movie like that
i i went and we were just talking about
this adam sandler movie that we love mr
deeds one of one of our i think one of
the funniest movies it's
and uh and billy madison happy gilmore
they got terrible reviews so like if you
say
that might classify mayor in your
definition as a terrible mediocre movie
right i think a lot certainly critics at
the time would have said that's a
terrible move that's true but god how
much joy it's brought me you know that's
true and as much fun as is to make a
movie there's something very selfish
about ima imagining making a movie that
no that's just for me making it
i know
and but sorry the first part of it was
uh make a you're great like something
you're really proud of that like your
closest friends and like you can pick
100 people to see or something i might
pick i might pick that too because i
certainly don't need the adulation but
yeah but i definitely need an audience
yeah that's true so i would have to pick
the second option by its fault and
life's greatest work implies that um
i don't know that that like
that that's gonna be it there's a
finality to that and and
and there's a completion there's like a
satisfaction and an ego satisfaction in
the completion of it which there
definitely always is but
for me i always my joy is in the making
of it like when i think back about the
movie it's
my favorite moments were the yeah it was
fun to see it the other night and
everything but like it's it was really
like doing it putting it together and
you know shooting it and being down
there and writing it i agree but
it wouldn't have been as satisfying i
would argue if you knew that not a
single person that is true that is true
so uh once again thank you lionsgate
uh number two uh another they're great i
like when they're too woody rather
because um
well because i like them number two
would you rather drive a car that honks
every time you break you can't get it
fixed or buy a new car or
have a car that you'd have to listen to
a song you hate in its entirety before
being able to drive it
like mr rabbi you know what comes to
mind is mr roboto
remember how crazy i would rather listen
i would rather listen to 10 songs i hate
before i drove before the first option
oh really because you break a lot in a
car i
also would cause and everyone you can
apologize oh constantly
someone uh
apologized to me through the opposite
they beeped at me
uh mistakenly the other day when i was
driving because uh i was at a red light
and i was taking a right and they just
the car behind me didn't see that there
was another car coming and i couldn't i
had to yield to them and they beeped at
me and i got so angry
i didn't do anything obviously
but i got angry with them for beeping at
me when i was just following the rules
so i would hate
to have
all these people think that about me
every time i broke me they would think
that i'm
mad at them right it would be awful
i once i once was i was driving my
friend's car and i
beeped the horn
because i saw a friend of mine of ours
and i was like
and it's a wave and there was like some
glitch happened in the car and the horn
just stayed on
and it was like
that's and i couldn't so i had to drive
but i was in traffic so i had to wait
until i could pull into a parking lot
and my friend was like dude stop he
thought i was holding on the horn i was
like i'm not doing anything
so we did go to the parking lot and pull
out the little um the little thing in
the little thing there's a little like
uh what's it called like a circuit oh
there oh you did yeah what car was that
it was a volvo it was doug's car
it was so embarrassing though it was
like ah
it was a good like it felt like an hour
but it was probably like 90 seconds
but it was a nightmare that is so funny
that should be in a movie
maybe if we get to do another one
that's so funny yeah i got a cr i got
cut off in such an aggressive way like
in a way that like i almost i had to
slam on my brakes they cut me off i was
in the second lane and then they like
slowed down and i was i do this thing
now on the road and meditation has
helped where i
when i feel angry or i feel like absurd
of something i just get like overly
friendly and i'm like hey whoa and i'm
like making these i mean i guess it's a
form of passive aggression
um has meditation helped uh yeah really
yeah it really has um but uh he so then
they
and then they like
got off really like driving erratically
and gave they got back into the other
lane and gave me the finger wow
it's like and then you hunted them down
and slashed
no i was just like i waved i truly i
wait i gave him a thumbs up when i get
the finger now i give the thumbs up you
give him a different finger yes yes
that is really funny about the car horn
and also i kind of like listening to bad
songs
it's like fun to hate songs yeah it was
yeah it'd be annoying if you're in a
rush and you had to listen to like oh
you know i'm getting closer to my you
know that song yeah
i'm getting closer to my own and it's
like it's like they ran out
lyrics on forever it's like they were so
i'm good but of
proud of that one lyric they were like
let's just do the whole song about this
it would be annoying until i have to
listen to that if you were late for
something i think mr roboto would be
more annoying
yeah maybe
and it's also that like
it's like that affected roboty voice
um oh you know have you have you been
enjoying me as roboto in the he-man
series
oh that's out
supportive uh p.s back to mayor i've
attached a photo of myself because i
think it's nice to have a face to
connect to the person writing to you
that's very nice i think other shorties
should do the same smiley face
you know it's and that's from mayor
michelle 28 pennsylvania you know what i
actually kind of think the opposite
there is something about
just
gleaning this about gleaning something
about somebody based on
what they've written
but i do get the argument for seeing it
is nice to connect
the whole time you've been reading i've
seen what she looks like because it's on
the back oh oh
hey wow she's so it's sort of nice oh my
god
who's writing it yeah she is and she
also happens to have a very nice face
she does have a version she looks like a
very like pleasant doesn't she look like
a really like cute sweet pre like
pleasant person she does and uh she's a
mug that says football dad uh but anyway
mayor thank you uh for including that
and for teaching us the lesson yes
and for ryan and we're sorry about your
loss very sorry uh and can definitely
empathize with you and thank you for
writing in and if you guys would like to
write in our email address is justin
life is short sorry that was misleading
it's not justin yeah no it's just life
is short wondering.com
and thank you to everyone who listened
and
again to the anyone who watched the
movie and mostly uh today thank you to
ryan for being such a gracious guest and
so patient and game and funny in our in
our first movie yeah we'll never forget
it never thanks thanks for having
great supple lips
yeah
we think that looks supple um
and uh yeah check out right and of
course check out mcgruber coming out
christmas i know what i'm doing this
christmas man i was i was i'm so
[ __ ] excited for that i cannot i
rarely look forward to like a thing
coming out um
man i can't wait so thanks to ryan and
uh and all of you and check out lady the
manor and we'll talk to you next week
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie the allen
senior producer on this michelle miesh
lance and there's an audio engineer
sergio enriquez and also don't forget
about the executive producer marshall
louise's name for wondering
[Music]
in fact i'm like the only thing i'm mad
about is that i didn't
take a picture no i know i can still
picture it in my head so clearly though
it was like
it was so noticeable we should so you
must've seen it right away
i didn't see it right away we sat down
that's the problem yeah i only saw it
once the interview started and i glanced
over at you to like
because you were saying something you
were answering a question
and i was like i looked over and i saw
all the schmutz on it but i just didn't
look at your face when you sat down you
know what it was i was eating one of
those like beyond i made like the beyond
burger and it was like
it got a little charred it was spilling
over the side of the bus
yeah so
it it clipped the side of my face like
this
so my face got like
it was like saucy and like burglary
i must not have like felt it
so funny
i'm like i don't obviously i don't want
you to be embarrassed oh that's so funny
but it'd be funny it was probably a
janky show
so like it wouldn't have mattered really
it would have been how funny would it be
if there was footage footage i know
of like well-lit footage
of an entire interview you would like
crap on like when does that ever happen
i don't i've never seen that
you